Almost a
year into Russia's war on Ukraine
and a top Ukrainian officials as Moscow
is planning another big
call up of troops in the months ahead.
Russia denies it, but the deputy head
of Ukraine's defense intelligence says
Russia is expected to mobilize up
to half a million additional troops
for operations in the east and south
Fierce fighting continues
in the eastern the town of Volodya
in the Donetsk region and in the city
where intense battles are ongoing.
In the Donetsk region and in other areas.
Special attention is paid to public mood,
toward defense,
to the occupiers, attempts to encircle
the city and break defense lines there.
We are reacting.
A Ukrainian general says the landscape
around the embattled city of government
provides natural defenses, so Ukrainian
fighters making it an unwinnable fortress.
This is the head of Russia's watchdog.
The mercenaries issued an online challenge
to Ukraine's president.
He he didn't like it
Wagner
boss Yevgeny
Prigozhin taking to the skies.
Flying a combat aircraft
challenging Ukraine's
president to a dogfight
I landed.
We bombed, bombed, he says.
Tomorrow I'm boarding a MiG 29,
if you desire.
We'll meet in the sky with still
Ukraine acknowledges
the Russians have made some gains around
Bermuda, but insist
they're suffering catastrophic losses.
The head of Ukraine's National Security
Council tells Globo is the lack of shells.
That is a significant disadvantage,
he says, but in our favor,
we are killing them
at a ratio of seven times to one.
Unfortunately, our men and women are dying
there as well.
Ukraine's
entire eastern front has been heating up.
The Russians deploying
tens of thousands of troops mobilized late
last year for what is expected
to be a massive spring offensive.
Even so,
Ukraine's Security Council
chief says his country is ready
not only China's a partner,
we're concerned,
he says, but I would stress
that we are preparing together
with our partners.
Good preparations are being made now.
So if the Russian offensive begins
it will be unsuccessful.
But to turn the tide of this war,
the Ukrainians say
they need more long range weapons to hit
Russian supply line
and combat aircraft
to win control of the skies.
They're confident of getting both,
eventually boost the home,
but they need to catch up.
It's only a matter of time until we get
F-16s, he says they will definitely come.
Unfortunately, in the meantime,
we're losing our people while fighting
for our independence,
which in Russian is always the Russians.
Say they foiled a drone attack deep inside
Russian territory.
Only about 140 miles from Moscow.
The Ukrainians have promised not to use
Western weapons to hit Russian territory.
But Daniel
Chief says Ukraine will use its own
facilities,
a territory regarding Russian territory.
Nobody prohibits us to destroy targets
with weapons produced in Ukraine, he says.
Do we have such weapons? Yes, we do.
For the Ukrainians, it's
a race against time
to secure and develop weapons
that will hold off what they call
Russia's revenge for taking.
CNN, Kiev, Ukraine,
Some members of the UN Security Council
called on Russia
to end the war in Ukraine, even as Ukraine
and the rest of the world
waits for Russia's widely expected
spring offensive.
During debate Monday, the US ambassador
pointed out that the ultimate decision
on this war remains with one man
We have heard your compassionate calls
for negotiation
for a cessation of hostility.
This is in the hands of one person.
President Putin alone.
Putin started this war
and he can end it today
by pulling his troops out of Ukraine and
and really allow for peace
to take place for Ukraine.
This is a matter of survival.
Almost one year into Vladimir Putin's
war of choice and clearly
he understood that the Ukrainian people
underestimated a 102 year old great
grandmother who's making camouflage
to provide cover for Ukrainian snipers.
Sam Kiley has a remarkable story.
The formative trauma of bullying at 102.
Lobov survival is extraordinary,
not least because she's endured
three famines over her century.
And all of them blamed on the Kremlin,
really, really poor.
We eat Linden, Linden, Leafs and nettles.
We used to grind this wild plants
into flour, bake with it and eat it.
Not a normal crew.
At 13, she saw her older
brother and sister perish
in Ukraine's worst mass starvation.
The Holodomor.
Oh, you hate your food here.
My legs were swollen.
My arms were swollen.
I was so sick,
I thought I was going to die.
My mom was in the early 1930s
on Josef Stalin's orders.
Ukraine's farmers were stripped
of every grain they produced
to feed Moscow's industrialization.
MAHLANGU
Tiny children were dying of hunger.
They were taken to a truck.
They dug a big hole and threw them
all in the barrel in a hotel.
Ukraine is now 11 months into the latest
Russian invasion.
Three of her grandchildren are soldiers
fighting Russian troops
because Russia's president doesn't believe
that Ukraine exists illegally.
It's totally populist.
It should be noted that
Ukraine actually never had stable
traditions of real statehood.
Putin claimed Russia's assault on
Ukraine's capital, Kiev, failed last year.
Many Ukrainians believe
they're fighting off another attempt
at genocide given to the leaders
and organizers of the genocide
sit in the same offices in the same place
at the center of these events in Moscow.
And the object of destruction is Ukraine
as a nation.
Ukraine's government says
thousands of citizens have been forced
into Russian territory
and 14,000 children are missing.
How many millions of people died
in the many famines
brought upon by Russia
in this country over the last century?
Is a matter of debate among historians.
And human rights lawyers will debate
whether or not what is happening
today can be defined as a genocide.
But there's no question that over the last
hundred years, the relationship
between Moscow and Ukraine has been bleak.
That more than a week
We need to exterminate them
so that not a single one is left.
Only then can there be any peace
here to help the war effort.
She ties burlap
into netting to make sniper camouflage.
But it may be her laughter
that has kept her going so many years
coming up that Red.
Sam Kiley, CNN, Pawtucket.